notre père qui est aux cieux que ton nom
soit sanctifié que ton règne vienne que
ta volonté soit faite
[Musique]
à main
père daniel garcia je vous présente le
père peter costello le bien daniel est
fortement recommandée c'est notre
nouvelle et meilleure recrue
qu'est-ce que l'archevêque tard à
condition
que vous êtes le meilleur exorciste ceux
qui ne t'a pas si c'est qu'ils peuvent
enseigner les prières mais ça ce n'est
pas ce qui nous différencie des prêtres
ordinaire il faut que tout soit prêt à
assumer des risques
change de vêtements leur semble à un
prêtre
un exorciste ne se cache jamais du mal
ils se ruent sur lui tu sais ce que j'ai
vu
l'incarnation du mal
ce petit a besoin des deux j'ai vu ça
aux infos ce matin
garçon a tué sa famille
qu'est ce que tu attends alors
je vous connais
père daniel
je vous ai vu en rêve
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
ou deux
le dumont et qu'elle le plus puissante
jamais vu
le diable est malin
il a besoin d'une armée
et une armée a besoin de stars
[Musique]
pour pouvoir se multiplier devenir de
plus en plus puissants
parce que j'ai un compte à régler
[Applaudissements]
non
[Musique]